this is a new variant
it's called duck chess I assume most
people have never seen this before
I only saw it for the first time
recently we can see the rules here might
have to squint to read this
but the duck the duck is a brick
does a quack though pieces cannot move
through the square occupied by the duck
but Knights can jump over the duck each
player's turn has two steps
after moving a piece the duck must be
moved to an empty Square there is no
check or checkmate
capture the poems King to win oh wow
though there's no stalemate the still
wait there is still meat but the still
made the player wins ooh
if only that was real chess
okay a lot of people challenging me
okay
it's time to play duck chess
where's the duck oh I guess white white
makes a move and then places a duck
yeah you can play this on um
it's just.com variants
so let's make a move
and then let's place a duck
I'm blocking White's bishop and queen
and king from developing
uh the anti-bong clown oh no I can't
take back
oh that's unfortunate
I fell I fell for a opening trap
oh that's so sad
wait this is annoying
wait how's my bishop ever going to
develop If he if the duck keeps being
placed on D7
okay let's take back
I wonder if that was a mouse if I wonder
if
my opponent meant to play duck D7
yeah
do I Mouse looked too
that's actually a pretty bad Mouse lift
because now the bishop I allowed the
bishop to develop
okay at least now I can win this Pawn
this is so funny
this is so mind-bending too like the
duck adds a whole new layer
of complexity
what does this move
I want to deliver check
what happens if I check
what happens if I do this and then this
because my point will have to move the
duck again
I think I don't know
it's so easy to plunger the king here I
think if you're white
oh
okay
play this again
ah they can just take back though
hmm
wait
this is so complex
so if I play there
and then move the dock
I want to sack the bishop
wait this is crazy man okay so Queen E7
Queen E7 duck ducky 2.
then my opponent takes and plays ducky
three I just lose a piece
yeah that's counterproductive
counterproductive
okay so I think I'll play this and then
this
no and then this uh
and then this okay
I didn't want to take because then the
Knight would just take back
man this could get weird really quickly
yeah like it's already getting kind of
weird
so Queen E2 I might as well Castle
and then play like this
preventing the Bishop from developing it
feels so good to move the duck but it
feels so bad when the duck is moved
in in my way
like there's all sorts of like different
tactics that can happen in this game
which I'm I'm trying to comprehend
I think I'll play this move
still resembles some normal chess
I think it's important to attack in
multiple lines like if I can have
multiple long distance
attacks
the duck can only block so much at once
oh yeah we have new notation here too
that's kind of cool
foreign
preventing castling delivered check
so it's interesting like white could
move move like Bishop G5 and then just
block the check with the duck
maybe I'm helping my opponent in some
way
yeah
so I've wanted to move the duck and then
take the pawn but I can only do so much
so Ducks actually have really annoying
defensive piece
maybe Knight G4
I'm trying to attack
keeping the white king in the center
oh you can Castle when you're in check
in this game
oh
cool shirt Eric oh thank you
this is just a boxer I appreciate the
compliments
actually there is a story behind this
shirt
because I didn't buy it myself
uh a friend got it for me
it's one of these um Lululemon shirts a
nice quality
but I um I was helping my friend during
a tournament
I've repaired like some cool opening
Trot that my friend used with pretty
good success
and then they got me a shirt as a gift
wow Knight D4 so let's move oh wait no I
can't move the duck
uh can I take the pawn and then
this is so mind-boggling
foreign
okay so let's check
oh I just plundered though
okay opponent doesn't punish me
uh how to do this
my Queen's attacked
look I'm in trouble here
unless I play this and then this
oh it's so confusing because now there's
this battery
I keep confusing the duck for like a
piece that can maybe be captured but we
have to I just have to get used to the
duck
it's like this new thing that
has just intruded in the game
oh what a confusing position because
what's like
basically what's going to happen is the
point will have to move the duck
off of this diagonal
unleashing the tension between the
Bishops quack times 14 thanks for all
the quacks oh thank you Jay-Z Safa
yeah quack quack it'd be cool if there
was some quack sound effects in this
game like every time the duck is placed
yeah that's a reasonable move
so if I take
I think I'll take and then play
I have this
I gotta watch my time
I think there's four second increment
oh I understand why there's four second
increments
because it's like double usually it's
two second agreement but because every
turn has two steps
they've doubled it to four
in Rose and angry goose
oh yeah where's the goose
the funny if there is just a goose that
randomly appears
he just eats the duck
okay let's oh wait no I have to I keep
wanting to move the duck first
is she wondering like what what's more
powerful in this game Knights are
Bishops
the knights might be better long term
because they're not affected by the duck
okay so I'm trying to maximize uh
all the directions I'm attacking
I'm also just preventing light from
castling every move
but you should always place a duck
in the way of your opponent's best move
if that makes sense
oh wow
oh that's a nasty move
wow this is a move
am I in trouble
oh wow what's going on
da
I'm in trouble
yeah I messed up oh no
check
I'm down a piece
maybe it's not so bad though
now opponent's actually pretty good at
Duck chess
they've also played before it looks like
because they have an established rating
wow it's going to be a duck time
scramble
what's happening
foreign
oh it's so confusing
let's go okay I won the rook and I
prevented Bishop from taking back
duct tactics
oh castling wow
oh it's so tricky
I'm up a rook
like this is gonna be a weird end game
I'm so confused
the duck is really throwing me off
I just have to realize the duck is
harmless
I should have played duck A3
can I make multi-premoves wow I can oh
no I pre-moved the wrong move though
that's okay
I guess once you make the first step you
can't make the second step
wait my Pawn can be blockaded
by the duck
oh I'm so confused
let's play this and then this yes it's
back ring checkmate
right no ah
okay
oh it's happening
okay another
keep opponent locked in
wait I should be careful not to
stalemate
because it's still meeting player
almost flagged
like if I put the duck on G1 it would be
stalemate I think
foreign
oh it's Chuck
I'm so scared of stamina I feel like a
beginner like not knowing how stalemate
works
foreign
wow I almost flagged there
does it still need
I'm so close to flagging I don't
understand how to win
huh
okay let's Checkmate I hope
if the Kings and Chaka can't be
stalemate oh that's not
okay I'm allowing the pawn to move
foreign
how do I win
I'm so confused
okay this has to be winning right
how does white survive
wow
okay there's no Escape
wow there is an escape
okay now there's no Escape right
there we go okay
oh that wasn't easy
like a game that took so much work
it's so difficult